it took you about a year to figure
things out so for I know a lot of people
looking thinking about starting like
they just want this thing to happen
after one week after one month or they
want Clarity all at once do you think
that's the wrong approach yeah I think
if you're going to take a shot at
YouTube there's a couple of things you
have to think about you know one is is
the goal the ad revenue is it money or
is it impact and for me it's always been
impact the money has been amazing and
frankly I had no idea would be what it
is already and it's growing you know
monthly yeah but impact was my thing
right I I came to this situation already
financially secure and YouTube's an
amazing place I could I touch people
every day thousands of people every day
I now get somewhere between 20 and 30
messages a day thanking me and it just
keeps you going I never want to stop
um I actually it's funny I did every day
for almost three years it got to the
point where I was like I need to I need
to back off so I start taking Fridays
and Saturdays off which I'm not always
good at yeah but I do take them off
occasionally but yeah it's about I give
it three hours a day five days a week
yeah so it's it just feels good it
really does that's powerful and what you
just shared there three hours a day five
days a week is what sustains all of the
content that you're creating and so
you've uploaded 10
000 videos yes it's a really shocking
number and it's cool to be having you on
the think media podcast at this moment
because that's a significant Milestone
you recently hit it yes YouTube Just
rounds it at this point so I mean I got
it I got a note uh I think it was six
weeks ago it might have been seven weeks
ago that my 10 000 video was loaded yeah
it's pretty wild and so what is the
system and workflow for publishing
content I go live at 7 30 a.m on the dot
worst case I'm a minute late which very
rarely happens but it's it's that
schedule so you can count on me being
live at 7 30 Pacific Sunday through
Thursday it goes for 12 to 18 minutes
based on the topics and I'm done yeah
that's it and to be even a little bit
more detailed now you have like a little
studio and a white board correct and
you've got a couple things going on so
it's turned into a show Absolutely and
again right this is the evolution right
in the beginning it was me just talking
to my phone then it was my computer and
then thanks to think media and what
you've shared I got a camera that you
recommended so thank you it's amazing
but yeah it's just grown up I took ad
revenue and invested back in the
business right I didn't I had the money
to go buy the toys but that wasn't it
wasn't about the toys it was it was
about getting better at my craft and it
just takes repetition so now it went
from my kids bedroom
um to a studio that's about a mile down
the road and it actually has three
different rooms in it right I carved it
up so my daily financial news is in the
middle it's all soundproof there's a
whiteboard and it's five topics and
again that's because of you right I used
to come in I used to say good morning
good afternoon good evening it's just I
would waste time the hook right to use
your language uh so again you always
have to be finding other mentors and
help getting better at your craft now
it's five things occasionally there's a
sixth thing that's kind of some random
thing but it's pretty much the same
format every day two things number one
I've had too much coffee today number
two if you have not seen our free master
class yet you're gonna love it if you're
serious about growing your YouTube
channel just go to
thinkmasterclass.com for a one hour Deep
dive on-demand YouTube strategy class
it's sick and uh I'm gonna go refill my
coffee hope to see you on the class